we're continuing to get to know this new
class of elected officials
in the house of representatives which
includes some
really really unqualified people we've
spoken before about marjorie taylor
greene who
drafted articles of impeachment against
joe biden on january 21st last week yes
she did
we talked earlier today about lauren
bobert uh we spoke earlier today about
madison cawthorne's disastrous interview
on cnn
you know to give you a sense of the sort
of folks that we're dealing with here
um there is pretty widespread reporting
about
madison cothorn visiting hitler's house
because it was a bucket list
item for him and everything about i mean
down to the
detail this is indistinguishable from
satire with some of these guys
um the jewish mayor of asheville north
carolina remember that madison cawthorne
is a representative now in north
carolina
back in august said it's very concerning
that the republican then candidate now
member of congress visited adolf
hitler's vacation home
and referred to him as the fuhrer on
social media
and back in 2017 kawthorne posted from
the so-called
eagles nest hitler's vacation home it
was one of the last battlegrounds of
world war
ii referred to hitler as the fuhrer
said that going there was on his bucket
list
and did call hitler a supreme evil right
i i'm not
looking to hide that from you
the mayor manheimer said it's very
concerning
throughout the last several years since
trump has been elected president
i think all of us have seen that white
supremacists are emboldened and
are publicly making their positions
known and to elect someone who openly
throws out dog whistles like this
it just makes me really sad actually
first and foremost
it makes me sad disappointed worried now
when this
was written about cowthorne briefly took
down the pictures because
a lot of attention was called to them
then they were publicly visible again
kawthorne deciding to double down and to
say that it's a fake news
controversy uh that he wasn't there to
celebrate he was celebrating
a victory over evil so i have a few
different
thoughts uh about this first of all as
someone who
who is disabled madison cawthorne would
have been one of the first killed by the
nazis right after jews
so that the irony of that is certainly
not
lost on me you'll very often hear
defenses from these folks like no
i was interested in seeing how such evil
was defeated or sometimes you'll hear
a a little more about well it was
interesting for historical reasons
visiting hitler's vacation home i'm a
his i'm an historian and it was
interesting for that or
reading mein kampf is interesting for
historical reasons
um i enjoy history as well but
when you see people flocking
to the hitler stuff for history's sake
but they're not interested in any other
areas of history
it is a little weird right like if
mineconf is the only history book you
read
you might not be that interested in
history and mein kampf isn't even really
a history book it's a historical book
for sure but it's not a book about
history
i'm no expert but very often when people
gravitate
to hitler's vacation home or reading
mind confident like that's the only
curiosity they have
it's not really about history it's that
they find the legacy of power and
violence
and ruthlessness exciting or interesting
and it's
i'm not denying that madison cawthorn
thinks hitler was
evil in some kind of nominal way
uh what i am sure of is that cawthorne
is a reactionary and a liar and we
should be very careful
about believing anything he says and i
don't know how many of you are aware of
the
history of lying uh madison cawthorne
misled the public about claiming he was
training for the paralympics
he misrepresented his educational
history he misrepresented his business
history
this seems like just a liar which
reminds me of someone by the way
multiple outlets have reported that
before running for office kawthorne said
he was training
for the 2020 paralympic games
there's no evidence of that whatsoever
corn wasn't on any team
or club he didn't run any races
it'd sort of be like if i said i'm
training for olympic ski jumping
but have you done any skiing to prepare
no
do you have a coach no are you on any
team
no do you have a lift ticket anywhere no
but i'm training like that's the degree
to which it seems that he was training
kawthorne claims to have been a
successful business owner
and uh heading to the naval academy when
his
tragic car accident left him paralyzed
but the truth is he had already been
rejected from the naval academy so it
wasn't true he was heading there
his only business that anyone was able
to find was a real estate investment
company
that had zero income and no employees
in 2019 so this seems like a liar
and when you talk about someone that
gets elected merely riding
riding the wings or standing on the
coattails
of donald trump in the trump cult this
is exactly who
you would imagine gets elected and we'll
be doing deep dives into lauren beaubert
we'll be doing deep dives into marjory
taylor greene
these are folks who know nothing about
policy or governance they are the
epitome
of cultish role players and we saw that
in madison cawthorne's
pamela brown interview earlier on in the
show and so
these folks really have to be defeated
in 2022.
if republicans learned anything from and
the trumpian fiasco and i don't know
that they have but as i said earlier
if they learned anything from the
trumpian fiasco
they would make sure to run credible
primaries against these folks
or to convince them to retire and that
they can't win um
i don't know that that's actually going
to happen but these folks if they get
re-elected would cement this trumpian
cult
um in the house of representatives for
multiple terms and that would be really
really scary and an
absolutely horrible thing